brauner bär ein brauner den stutzen und
kuscheln
muss ich sehen wie ich dem braunbären
töte ja geil mach mal wir geben richtig
hart ins gesicht
ich mache sie mitkommen hallo ich habe
eine person umgebracht haben wären fast
getötet
ich habe ein paar rohstoff zusammen
gesammelt und ich habe direkt zweimal
regeln missachtet bei uns läuft auf
jeden fall einen wunderschönen guten
tage lieber minecraft freunde
freundinnen und sonstige menschen die
hierher geschafft haben
es geht los es geht los und ich bin
dabei und mich kennt niemand aber dass
es vollkommen egal hier ist statt blau
die mit den langen himmeln wie sieht's
aus
dabei stellt uns halt mal vor wir sagen
vorher noch in der tss wachsen
hallo ich bin noch dabei in kraft da
halo und zunächst auch dabei heizte
bonnie schlimmsten stop-loss hat halt
gerade die ansage macht derzeit auch
noch dazu gekommen und wir werden uns
jetzt in gruppen aufteilen und dann
werden wir brocken sams mit rewe kev mit
sonic und ich mit keynotes werden ihr
zusammen aufnehmen das werdet ihr dann
auf den einstellen einzelnen channels
sehen die auch alle der beschreibung und
verlinkt sind da werden wir ganz ganz
große bühne kämpfe machen
wer könnte da auf jeden fall über noch
vorbeischauen und dann will ich sagen
wir uns jetzt nach einem kurzen katyn
der aufnahme wieder zu
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zur
ersten folge von minecraft über projekt
zusammen mit kates der geil sein rechter
arm ist lustig ist super und sport läuft
auf jeden fall rechne mit chaos auf ja
ein bisschen gesplittet und das ist die
erste folge von ein herz
mit der tour das reglement zweifel tenno
der staat gut wieder hier hin
man sollte vielleicht noch zu erwähnen
so nebenbei weil bestimmte viele wissen
clubs sind was ich hier machen wir gehen
erst mal hier mit unserem in die blaue
stadt die blaue stadt dass ich von allem
stände mit bekommen ab dass ich dabei
bin ja jedes ist jetzt dabei die gründe
werden wir eventuell nachher noch
irgendwas sagen das ist auf jeden fall
erstmal unsere stadt wo wir uns
unterlassen werden zornig und kathrin
auch schon hier mit dabei am start
in dem auch schon gerade auf und werde
ich gefordert was los als ob nicht ich
glaube darauf herum gegangen ist
passiert gar nichts
gbp
gut das ist auf jeden fall unsere stadt
leute das wird auf jeden fall hammergeil
und kate aus und ich damals gesagt
werden letztmals zum ersten mal sind
auch bildeten dreht kurze erste folgen
ihr solltet ihr mal einfach in den
kommentaren schreiben erst mal auf jeden
fall hashtag 2 ist baba stadt das könnt
ihr bei mir immer darunter schreiben das
ist nämlich einfach so soll etwa 8000
mal nacheinander aber ohne witz der
teleporter freiwillig der teleporter
funktioniert gar nicht nee ich laufe da
drauf um diese dann zu neben simon hoch
ok dann unterstützt jedoch hat hier ein
bisschen problemchen egal ich mir hier
schon mal ein bisschen holz und werde
mich dann hier wahrscheinlich dahin
wieder zu bauen
ich habe jeden fall pläne dafür was ich
mir von haus bauen werde die sache ist
aber okay wir stehen da ganz viele
monster am start
alle reden von einem zombie weg und um
die reporter rum das ist megageil das
stütze moment dann hole ich jetzt mal
kurz 7 und sogar von dem taxi versteckt
hat mal okay gut ich mache mir grad noch
mal eben einen schweren fall hammergeil
pläne was ich hier irgendwie so bauen
möchte an sachen allerdings habe ich
noch nicht so die ahnung von exit ich
habe noch nicht sogar die anderen hätten
das heißt wenn ihr da ihnen die bock
drauf habt könnt ihr mir ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz viele sachen in die
kommentare schreiben
irgendwas zu häckseln was ihr darüber
kennt und so da wäre ich auf jeden fall
richtig froh darüber
und die kommt nochmal schreiben was ihr
allgemein oder können einen daumen hoch
geben wenn ihr findet dass unsere stadt
die barockstadt ins
es ist doch einfach so oder unter ihr
findet das drei stunden teleporter
rumlaufen auch unglaublich bar ist dann
genauso gleich ist wirklich geil welche
das läuft auf blau rgb das läuft um den
dienst rumlaufen das ding oben wer wenn
sie irgendwann gehen würde und die
stelle border richtig zu
ich habe mein emerald chart alters das
will werde ich weiß es nicht ich habe
jeglichen ganze mir in den comments was
hast du lächerlichen du hast gar nichts
läuft könnte groß herum könnte ich nicht
theoretisch auch nächsten es hat ja
niemand ob die auf diesem server
seitigen zusatz recht oder so aber sind
auf jeden fall hammergeil dieses
komplette projekt und wir freuen uns
alle richtig
ich hole mir jetzt erstmal bisschen
weizen im schon mal ein bisschen damit
ich ein bisschen nahrung machen kann
weil natürlich wenn man stets macht es
dem herz geht aus von anfang wäre
natürlich wenn ich auf dem teleporter
lauf dann passiert einfach nichts über
den aufnahmen drin
dann bist du nicht eingetragen worden
weil das noch nicht so sicher waren
bisher relativ frisch drin ich komme
sofort und dann werde ich das beheben
moment
egal anderen hat's geklappt ja ich bin
mal wieder das einzige opfer hier bei
uns hat alles geklappt hat mir der name
war dem team nicht so klar
und jetzt ist auch schwierig weil es
genau main kanal wird ist sehr schwierig
aus kitas oder einfach nur kate austen
oder herr tutorial vielleicht auch auf
das programm ihr alles einfach mit dem
kopf auf der fan 97
denn man ist ja natürlich klar ok ok
moment dann komme ich mal in der simon
man darf sich doch einfach so eine stadt
ran boxen dinges tombi kinos
wenn du stirbst du mein lieber luca nein
schnauze bist du gestorben
nein wir haben paar späßchen gemacht
aber das war nur aus versehen alte fotos
versehen
das war auch junge geht das ist bald
gestorben was er alles ins spiel
reingekommen dessen spiel reingekommen
moment kurz geweckt von dem ok die erste
folge ist auch ein bisschen ungeordnet
jede mission aber das wird auf jeden
fall besser ein bisschen kaputt
ok ich werde mich jetzt erstmal
versuchen dass ich mir ein paar
vernünftige sachen basteln kann ich
nehme jetzt mal ein paar katja vielen
mit simon l natürlich auch alle manado
ganz ausschließen werde mich getötet hat
was er hat mich schon vor aufnahme
lautet nein in der aufnahme drin aber
das anders herum geboxt am start das war
und er ist direkt neben das tor bitte
faxen eigentlich simon am folgetag dann
aber lasst euch pvp ding das sich im pvp
ding passiert ist und ist noch nicht
eindeutig geklärt wurde
was dann passiert werden wir es einfach
mal gelernt einfach dabei belassen die
genauen regeln werde ich euch auch noch
mal alle erklären leute kommen ist der
ersten folge gestorben und er musste
dann
so aber jetzt nicht am teleporter
gestorben bevor den richtig los geht es
also für das bleibt immer hier am
telefon stehen am teleport brauner bär
ein brauner bei erreicht den stoppball
allein kuscheln
manchmal machen bis zu wenig gerade auch
solche wagen geschmissen und ich wüsste
nicht wie man bremst
ich fühle mich im puff ohne dass ich das
hier ist dein links du weißt schon bei
meinem ein dings meine ja klar logisch
mein tisch gewischt
wo bin ich lauf darum hier guck mal da
ja hier so einem jahr hier gilt wie ich
mich wirklich dämlichen braunbären töte
ja geil manchmal wir geben richtig hart
ins gesicht
ich mache sie mit komm ich okay dass das
war leider jetzt wirklich den tod
du bist auch gestorben conny coni hat
gefällige nie verschlossen
ach ich durfte ja gar nicht wie ich das
gemacht hast alles okay du bist ein
tolles bild
ich bin gerade die so stark da stand 20
punkte luca du bist raus bis jemand dein
grabstein zum friedhof bringt der stadt
einfach in die stadt bringt es muss
einfach sagt jemand einfach jemand seine
friedhof abbauen weitermacht schreiben
also ich hab ja so keine ahnung von
x-raid also ich werde mich noch mal alle
regeln einlesen euch das auch noch mal
vorstellen hier so eine regel folge ich
bin wohl tot ist und dass grabstein ab
und setzt die mal irgendwohin wo ein
friedhof entstehen soll international
folge das darf sich weiter spiele der
fall weiterspielen weil dort grabsteine
haben wir heute tag eine aufnahme sperre
also wenn man stirbt der folgetag auf
eine sperre und jedoch nur einmal
wiederbelebt werden
das tötet erst als erster kiel weil er
eben das mit dem boxen zählte ja nicht
wenn ihr noch mal stirbt
seid ihr raus das herrliche aufnahme
dieser aufnahme ist vorbei und die zwölf
stunden später dann vom server spitze
gut auf und spielt auf dem höchsten
schwierigkeitsgrad ins gibt ich hab
schon gemerkt aber wir sind sehr clever
seit wann weiß ich dass ich dass ich
jetzt gerade hier auf weiß dass er seit
einer stunde ungefähr regeln wurden mir
erzählt klammer öffentliche regel
dokumente oder hast du auch sehr das ist
cool 7
sie wird auf jeden fall erstmal bisschen
schief an flickr vor okay geht bitte bei
sind definitiv vor wenn ihr noch einmal
stärke ist leider für euch die heutige
folge schon zu ende
geil das fühlt sich gut an dass ich bin
einfach jedes wollen wir wollen wir
zusammenziehen
danke tschüss geben wir sind freunde vom
meer also ich glaube das darf ich darf
wieder rein
ja klar das team daran haben die
grabsteine was hat er geht für
augenbrauen
keystone oder was los du willst doch
respawn okay aber du musst auch das
aufnehmen da nimmst du daran tragen dass
nora tschirner in alle netze auf den
vertagt am besten ist aller wirklich
wenn ihr euch jetzt ein bett macht dass
sie auch wirklich statt also unsere
grabsteine wurden jetzt hierhin geplatzt
hier kann wo wir zwar nicht gestorben
sind aber die den ganz nebeneinander und
jambi dahingestellt
der friedhof aber wir werden noch ein
friedhof herum bauen ich hol dich geh
doch holt mich mal chaos wird noch
besser leute ja chaos ist gar kein
ausdruck dafür reichen die tib
teleporter sollten auch eigentlich ein
einziges mal benutzt werden wenn man
stirbt ist ja sowieso also bewusst ein
friedhof jetzt erstmal ein
provisorischer ich zeig euch den mega
trauen wo bist du ja hier ist der bedarf
in boxen da stehen zwei grabsteine also
okay da ist der friedhof
ich versuche jetzt mal mit schafe zu
finde ich sie da hinten schon nix geil
okay man muss auf jeden fall
vorsichtiger vorgehen
wo es zonen und konto auf das starb beim
anal und wirkt wurst so es sind die
behinderten hier mit uns die beherzten
sind das älteste cottbuser gestorben mit
dem braunbär ist aber vorstellen
bombardiert
bei mannheim jetzt ein braunbär passt
jetzt wirklich gut auf das nicht der
wirklich aus ich bleib ich hole mir
jetzt scharfe und ich wurde holte dann
lege ich mich einfach mein ganzes leben
lang im bett rein
ich bin jetzt am server herunter weil
meine aufnahme startet erst zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt bis spätestens wenn
auch was ist ruft mich an oder sagt
bescheid na ja klar
los jetzt jetzt wollen wir baumann
ressourcen oder die kann man ja ganz
normal sich besorgen möchte lahm
allerdings ist meine zeit auch schon
wieder fast am ende hier das war
megageil sste erste vorne
die sind gestorben wir haben irgendwie
alle regeln missachtet und das könne
halt einfach nur jeder seite aber ich
dachte ich finde aber keine scharfe
keine schafe ja irgendwo du ich hab ich
nichts gemacht außer rumzuhüpfen wo soll
ich denn wirklich eine tolle herkriegen
für meine form und ich meine in den
häusern von denen das ist also ich hab
schafe gefunden wir ehrlich ja gut dann
schnell da macht man sich eben bett das
ist etwas ziel und danach muss man dann
stoppt und dann in der nächsten folge
also wenn man auch erstmal dann ging's
dann dürfen einander ja ja ja nix leute
das heißt die erste folge gab es ist auf
jeden fall morgen gibt's nicht
übermorgen geht es dann los
und also
ja direkt gestorben bitte erzählt dass
keinem anderen dass wir direkt gestorben
bin das ist irgendwie bitte nicht soll
geheim bleiben auf jeden fall was so
geschehen am start
ich hab mich meine spitzhacke und mir im
beavers oscar ich habe auch nichts
dadurch gesagt aber dass das nicht ich
sehe da hinten den weißen bären alter
ich will mich wären auf jeden fall nicht
nochmals zu nähern
die schlechteste aller respekt das ist
hier sind einfach dibaba sie sind das
geil war wir hatten noch nie probleme
irgendwie am anfang weil weil ich halt
erst angefangen habe hier mit dem
projekt ohne zu wissen was ich damit
anfangen und bei conny lieferung was
nicht richtig
und das ist erst mal megalan glaubst du
angefangen aufzunehmen und acom wenn die
hat eben unsere aufnahme hier in der
kirche
ok damit wir nicht antreten dass wir
damit wir was die haben gesagt wir
morgen keine zeit hat sie als erledigt
ja wir haben heute morgen deswegen
patrol versteck erstmal druckvoll aber
ich hab selbst an zudem findet
inzwischen so wir werden jetzt unsere
aufnahme hier oben drauf machen noch ein
abstieg aus der volle leben also ich hab
angst vor leuten
wir würden sagen hat euch gefallen dann
gibt einen mäßigen daumen hoch wenn ihr
auf jeden fall bekommen erfolgen habt
ich würde gerne morgen wieder was
hochladen ich habe allerdings keine
möglichkeit dazu
weil ich halt schon gestorben der erste
der zwei war gestorben
ja ich habe eine person umgebracht haben
während fast getötet
ich habe ein paar rohstoff zusammen
gesammelt und ich habe direkt zweimal
regeln missachtet und bei uns läuft auf
jeden fall
wir sind total legitim das waren haben
wir diesmal wieder schaut bei allen
anderen teilnehmern in der beschreibung
vorbei und schütteln